This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.|||这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都无法真正安全进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位深谙此道的持牌专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套或多套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须去这样做，请收听
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,|||在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.|||更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“2%”，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.|||请收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎来到《回看过去》（Look Back at It）播客。从1979年开始，那对我和说是个大日子。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.|||与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真的是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个带你探讨二十岁人生中的重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're covering a really valuable idea in psychology and one that has become increasingly, I would say more recognized. Maybe you've seen it on your TikTok, on Instagram, in the news. It's this idea of hyper-independence. I am so fascinated by this concept because I think independence is possibly one of the most celebrated traits in our society, particularly in Western cultures. We love the idea of people who are self-made,
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're covering a really valuable idea in psychology and one that has become increasingly, I would say more recognized. Maybe you've seen it on your TikTok, on Instagram, in the news. It's this idea of hyper-independence. I am so fascinated by this concept because I think independence is possibly one of the most celebrated traits in our society, particularly in Western cultures. We love the idea of people who are self-made,|||大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目。今天，我们要探讨心理学中一个非常有价值的概念，而且我认为这个概念正变得越来越被人所认知。也许你已经在你的TikTok、Instagram或新闻中见过它了。这就是“过度独立”的概念。我对这个概念着迷不已，因为我认为独立可能是我们社会中最受推崇的特质之一，尤其是在西方文化中。我们非常欣赏那些白手起家的人，
who pay their own bills, who solo travel, who appear like they don't need anyone but themselves. And I think a healthy level of independence and self-confidence is amazing. It's something that we should all strive for. But when it goes too far, we enter the territory of high. hyper independence. This is this extreme discomfort around allowing others to help us,
who pay their own bills, who solo travel, who appear like they don't need anyone but themselves. And I think a healthy level of independence and self-confidence is amazing. It's something that we should all strive for. But when it goes too far, we enter the territory of high. hyper independence. This is this extreme discomfort around allowing others to help us,|||他们自己付账单，独自旅行，看起来除了自己谁也不需要。我认为健康的独立和自信是了不起的。这是我们所有人都应该努力去追求的。但当它走向极端时，我们就进入了“高度/过度独立”的领域。这是一种极度抗拒让别人来帮助我们的状态，
to step into our lives and maybe make it easier. We become so invested in our self-reliance and our self-sufficiency that we push others away and we self-isolate. A lot of the research nowadays says that hyper-independence is actually a trauma response. or a survival trait that a lot of us have adopted due to early childhood experiences, feeling like we needed to grow up way too quickly or being consistently let down by others, particularly our caregivers, but also romantic partners or friends. These experiences are so distressing that we turn to extreme independence to avoid having, to rely on others or trust them out of that fear of being hurt or let down. And a lot of the time,
to step into our lives and maybe make it easier. We become so invested in our self-reliance and our self-sufficiency that we push others away and we self-isolate. A lot of the research nowadays says that hyper-independence is actually a trauma response. or a survival trait that a lot of us have adopted due to early childhood experiences, feeling like we needed to grow up way too quickly or being consistently let down by others, particularly our caregivers, but also romantic partners or friends. These experiences are so distressing that we turn to extreme independence to avoid having, to rely on others or trust them out of that fear of being hurt or let down. And a lot of the time,|||介入我们的生活并让生活变得更轻松。我们过于执着于自力更生和自给自足，以至于把其他人推开，陷入自我孤立。如今的许多研究表明，过度独立实际上是一种创伤反应。或者是我们许多人由于早年童年经历而采用的一种生存特征，比如觉得自己被迫过快长大，或者不断遭到他人（尤其是我们的照顾者，也包括浪漫伴侣或朋友）的失望对待。这些经历是如此痛苦，以至于我们转向极端的独立，以此来避免不得不依赖他人或信任他人，从而免受伤害或失望的恐惧。而且很多时候，
I think society somewhat encourages this behavior without realizing what it actually means. This has so many complex interactions with how we pursue relationships, how we approach our work. It may come as no surprise that people who are hyper-independent are more likely to be seen as overachievers, but also how we experience love and trust. It's also really interesting because hyper-independent people are actually more likely to seek out codependent partnerships, which if you listened to our episode on this, you'll know is equally as complex and maladaptive. It really goes to show how much our attachment influences the people that we choose to be with, not just romantically, but the friends we choose to have our relationships with family.
I think society somewhat encourages this behavior without realizing what it actually means. This has so many complex interactions with how we pursue relationships, how we approach our work. It may come as no surprise that people who are hyper-independent are more likely to be seen as overachievers, but also how we experience love and trust. It's also really interesting because hyper-independent people are actually more likely to seek out codependent partnerships, which if you listened to our episode on this, you'll know is equally as complex and maladaptive. It really goes to show how much our attachment influences the people that we choose to be with, not just romantically, but the friends we choose to have our relationships with family.|||我认为社会在某种程度上鼓励了这种行为，却没有意识到它真正的含义。这与我们追求感情的方式、对待工作的方式有着许多复杂的互动。过度独立的人往往更容易被视为追求卓越者（overachievers），这或许并不让人意外，它也影响着我们体验爱与信任的方式。同样非常有趣的是，过度独立的人实际上更有可能去寻找共生依赖（codependent）的伙伴关系，如果你听过我们关于这个话题的那期节目，你就会知道这种关系同样复杂且适应不良。这充分说明了我们的依恋模式如何严重影响我们选择与之相伴的人，不仅是恋爱关系，还包括我们选择交的朋友以及与家人的关系。
So today, I want to talk about the role of hyper-independence as a trauma response and explore some of the origins of this behaviour from emotional neglect to parentification, abandonment and early relationship experiences, of course, but also the role of individualism and cultural expectations. we're also going to dive into how we can achieve a healthy level of independence through exposure therapy and inner child healing, an all-time favorite of mine as we know. This is a jam-packed episode, but I will admit some of the research and studies have definitely called me out and really made me pause and examine perhaps some of my own hyper-independent tendencies.
So today, I want to talk about the role of hyper-independence as a trauma response and explore some of the origins of this behaviour from emotional neglect to parentification, abandonment and early relationship experiences, of course, but also the role of individualism and cultural expectations. we're also going to dive into how we can achieve a healthy level of independence through exposure therapy and inner child healing, an all-time favorite of mine as we know. This is a jam-packed episode, but I will admit some of the research and studies have definitely called me out and really made me pause and examine perhaps some of my own hyper-independent tendencies.|||所以今天，我想谈谈过度独立作为一种创伤反应的角色，并探讨这种行为的一些根源，从情感忽视到亲职化（parentification）、遗弃感以及早期的恋爱经历，当然还有个人主义和文化期望的作用。我们还将深入探讨如何通过暴露疗法和内在小孩疗愈来实现健康的独立水平，众所周知，这也是我一直以来的最爱。这是一期内容满满的节目，但我必须承认，其中一些研究和调研确实“点醒”了我，让我不得不停下来，审视自己身上可能存在的某些过度独立倾向。
I think you'll be surprised by how many of us actually fit this profile. So without further ado, we are going to explore the psychology of hyper-independence in our 20s and how we can recognize this behavior and heal. So let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
I think you'll be surprised by how many of us actually fit this profile. So without further ado, we are going to explore the psychology of hyper-independence in our 20s and how we can recognize this behavior and heal. So let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||我想你会惊讶地发现，我们当中有多少人实际上都符合这种特征。闲话少说，接下来我们将探讨二十岁时过度独立的心理学，以及我们如何识别这种行为并进行疗愈。让我们进入正题吧。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're|||我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本身具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“TWO%”，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（或：袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在
thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.
thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know.|||想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？你可以在《回看过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.|||我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你帮我把这句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and comments. conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and comments. conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase|||请在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及评论。与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?|||以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her. Her story.
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her. Her story.|||还是说你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索“Learn the hard way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她身上惊人的矛盾之处。她的故事。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.|||这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。你在某些地方两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来侦破此案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love, Trapp. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud
Greg Alespian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love, Trapp. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud|||格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼（Michael Naranini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trapp）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌诈骗已被起诉
charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We typically see independence as a great thing, a really, admirable asset or personality trait, especially in our 20s when I think independence is something we're all striving for, to be separate from our parents, to be creating our own identity, building our own unique path. A lot of the positive associations we see attached to this are really valid.
charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We typically see independence as a great thing, a really, admirable asset or personality trait, especially in our 20s when I think independence is something we're all striving for, to be separate from our parents, to be creating our own identity, building our own unique path. A lot of the positive associations we see attached to this are really valid.|||指控。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。我们通常认为独立是一件伟大的事情，是一种非常令人钦佩的资产或个性特质，尤其是在我们的二十多岁时，我认为独立是我们所有人都在努力追求的东西，即脱离父母，创造我们自己的身份认同，构建我们自己独特的道路。我们看到与之相关的许多积极联系确实都是成立的。
To be independent is to be self-sufficient, have a healthy sense of your identity, you pay your own bills, you take care of yourself, you don't rely on others for emotional reassurance. That's something that I think we can all get behind. However, too much of a good thing can sometimes be bad for us. And with anything that is excessive or unbalanced, when independence goes too far, perhaps due to a trauma response or early learning experiences, we have this hyperindependence or what we also call counter dependency. When we are hyper-independent, we have a drive to need no one and a fear of depending on people at the heart of which is this inability to trust or a genuine
To be independent is to be self-sufficient, have a healthy sense of your identity, you pay your own bills, you take care of yourself, you don't rely on others for emotional reassurance. That's something that I think we can all get behind. However, too much of a good thing can sometimes be bad for us. And with anything that is excessive or unbalanced, when independence goes too far, perhaps due to a trauma response or early learning experiences, we have this hyperindependence or what we also call counter dependency. When we are hyper-independent, we have a drive to need no one and a fear of depending on people at the heart of which is this inability to trust or a genuine|||独立意味着自给自足，对自己的身份有健康的认知，自己付账单，照顾好自己，不依赖他人来寻求情感上的安慰。这是我认为我们所有人都能支持的事情。然而，好事过头有时也会对我们有害。对于任何过量或失衡的事物来说，当独立走得太远时，也许是由于创伤反应或早期的学习经历，我们就会产生这种过度独立，或者我们也称之为反依赖（counter dependency）。当我们过度独立时，我们会有一种不需要任何人的驱动力，并且害怕依赖他人，其核心是这种无法信任他人或对亲密关系的真正
fear of intimacy. Hyper-independence, it's more than just self-reliance. It's this unwavering insistence on autonomy. These kinds of people they are unwilling to or maybe unable. to depend on others. We want to do everything alone. We have been implicitly taught that we cannot trust others,
fear of intimacy. Hyper-independence, it's more than just self-reliance. It's this unwavering insistence on autonomy. These kinds of people they are unwilling to or maybe unable. to depend on others. We want to do everything alone. We have been implicitly taught that we cannot trust others,|||恐惧。过度独立，它不仅仅是自力更生。它是对自主性坚定不移的坚持。这类人他们不愿意或者可能无法去依赖别人。我们想独自完成所有事情。我们被潜移默化地教导说，我们不能信任别人，
so we push those close, vulnerable relationships away. We refuse help or assistance, both emotional and physical. Importantly, I think there's a crucial caveat here. Hyperindependence, it's not a diagnosable mental
so we push those close, vulnerable relationships away. We refuse help or assistance, both emotional and physical. Importantly, I think there's a crucial caveat here. Hyperindependence, it's not a diagnosable mental|||所以我们把那些亲密的、脆弱的关系推开。我们拒绝任何情感上和身体上的帮助或援助。重要的是，我认为这里有一个至关重要的前提。过度独立，它不是一种可诊断的精神
health condition. It's a stress response. More often than not, triggered by exposure to ongoing or acute distress or some kind of emotionally charged situation. So how does that kind of show up in our behaviors in our everyday lives? There are five key signs or indicators of hyper-independence that I want to discuss. Firstly, it feels really uncomfortable or unnatural for you to ask for help, specifically due to this fear of being a burden.
health condition. It's a stress response. More often than not, triggered by exposure to ongoing or acute distress or some kind of emotionally charged situation. So how does that kind of show up in our behaviors in our everyday lives? There are five key signs or indicators of hyper-independence that I want to discuss. Firstly, it feels really uncomfortable or unnatural for you to ask for help, specifically due to this fear of being a burden.|||健康状况。它是一种应激反应。通常情况下，它是由长期或急性的痛苦，或某种充满情绪化的情境所触发的。那么，这种状态在我们的日常生活和行为中是如何表现出来的呢？我想讨论过度独立的五个关键迹象或指标。首先，向别人寻求帮助会让你觉得非常不舒服或极不自然，这主要是出于害怕成为别人负担的恐惧。
Hyper independence creates this sense that anything we need, we should be able to do for ourselves. If you're feeling sad and upset, we can take care of that. We can self-soothe, we can manage it. If we need help moving or building furniture, we can't ask for help because it may burden someone else. And what does that say about our own abilities and our ability to take care of ourselves? You know if we're struggling financially, even if we need extra assistance, we're not going to ask for that. We're going to get another job or budget excessively.
Hyper independence creates this sense that anything we need, we should be able to do for ourselves. If you're feeling sad and upset, we can take care of that. We can self-soothe, we can manage it. If we need help moving or building furniture, we can't ask for help because it may burden someone else. And what does that say about our own abilities and our ability to take care of ourselves? You know if we're struggling financially, even if we need extra assistance, we're not going to ask for that. We're going to get another job or budget excessively.|||过度独立营造出这样一种观念：任何我们需要的需求，我们都应该能够自己解决。如果你感到悲伤和沮丧，我们自己就能搞定。我们可以自我安慰，我们可以应付。如果我们搬家或组装家具需要帮助，我们不敢开口，因为这可能会加重别人的负担。这又说明了我们自己的能力以及照顾自己的能力如何呢？你知道的，如果我们面临经济困境，即使我们需要额外的援助，我们也不会去开口。我们会再找一份工作或者过度节衣缩食。
Not only does asking for help feel entirely unnatural, it's actually really uncomfortable because it contradicts this identity that we've built on being entirely self-reliant. Emotionally, we may have difficulty with vulnerability and trust and therefore have limited. emotionally close relationships. Vulnerability requires asking for help. Trust means believing that someone has your best interests at heart and will fulfill your needs, none of which aligns with our self-image as an independent person. There's this voice in the back of our head saying, I really don't need anyone. I can do this alone.
Not only does asking for help feel entirely unnatural, it's actually really uncomfortable because it contradicts this identity that we've built on being entirely self-reliant. Emotionally, we may have difficulty with vulnerability and trust and therefore have limited. emotionally close relationships. Vulnerability requires asking for help. Trust means believing that someone has your best interests at heart and will fulfill your needs, none of which aligns with our self-image as an independent person. There's this voice in the back of our head saying, I really don't need anyone. I can do this alone.|||寻求帮助不仅让人觉得极其不自然，实际上还非常难受，因为它与我们建立的“完全自力更生”的自我认同相矛盾。在情感上，我们在展现脆弱和信任方面可能会遇到困难，因此我们的情感亲密关系会很有限。脆弱需要开口求助。信任意味着相信某人真心为你好，并且会满足你的需求，而这些都与我们作为独立之人的自我形象不符。我们的脑海深处总有个声音在说：“我真的不需要任何人。我一个人就能搞定。”
And that voice comes from a fear of being hurt. And so we use hyper independence to protect us from intimacy and vulnerability. And that's going to require us to open up to someone else. I think it's no surprise that especially in romantic relationships, this can come from previous experiences with betrayal, maybe due to cheating or lying, even heartbreak. So after those experiences, because they are so unpleasant, our brains go the complete opposite direction. If love and intimacy, if relying on someone else brings pain,
And that voice comes from a fear of being hurt. And so we use hyper independence to protect us from intimacy and vulnerability. And that's going to require us to open up to someone else. I think it's no surprise that especially in romantic relationships, this can come from previous experiences with betrayal, maybe due to cheating or lying, even heartbreak. So after those experiences, because they are so unpleasant, our brains go the complete opposite direction. If love and intimacy, if relying on someone else brings pain,|||那个声音源于对受到伤害的恐惧。因此，我们利用过度独立来保护自己免受亲密关系和脆弱感的伤害。而这需要我们向另一个人敞开心扉。我认为这并不奇怪，尤其是在恋爱关系中，这可能源于以往遭受背叛的经历，也许是因为出轨或说谎，甚至是心碎。因此，在经历过这些之后，由于它们是如此令人不快，我们的大脑会走向完全相反的方向。如果爱与亲密，如果依赖别人会带来痛苦，
well then relying only on myself brings liberation. It brings peace. We know, though, that that's not always true. This links to the next indicator, which is that you naturally close yourself off to others and you're suspicious when people try and get close. That suspicion or hostility may actually be because you don't actually trust yourself. What if someone does provide you with something you can't give yourself?
well then relying only on myself brings liberation. It brings peace. We know, though, that that's not always true. This links to the next indicator, which is that you naturally close yourself off to others and you're suspicious when people try and get close. That suspicion or hostility may actually be because you don't actually trust yourself. What if someone does provide you with something you can't give yourself?|||那么，只依赖自己就会带来解放。它会带来平静。然而我们知道，事实并非总是如此。这就联系到了下一个迹象，那就是你会自然而然地把自己对他人封闭起来，当别人试图走近时，你会心存怀疑。这种怀疑或敌意实际上可能是因为你根本不相信自己。万一有人真的提供了你无法给自己的东西呢？
What if they do fulfill some unmet need? And then they leave. And you can no longer fulfill that need yourself. The whole system kind of falls apart, the whole self-concept. You can no longer solely trust yourself. and so you make it impossible for anyone to ever get close enough to challenge that belief system. That emotional withdrawal is a massive indicator of hyper-independence. The fourth indicator is that you're an overachiever or a workaholic.
What if they do fulfill some unmet need? And then they leave. And you can no longer fulfill that need yourself. The whole system kind of falls apart, the whole self-concept. You can no longer solely trust yourself. and so you make it impossible for anyone to ever get close enough to that belief system. That emotional withdrawal is a massive indicator of hyper-independence. The fourth indicator is that you're an overachiever or a workaholic.|||万一他们真的满足了你某些未被满足的需求呢？然后他们离开了。而你却再也无法自己满足那个需求了。整个系统有点崩溃了，整个自我概念都瓦解了。你再也不能单单依靠自己了。所以你让任何人都不可能足够接近到去挑战那一套信仰体系。这种情感上的退缩是过度的一个巨大信号。第四个迹象是，你是一个追求卓越者（overachiever）或工作狂。
Your performance and success works to further support the belief that your hyper-independence is a good thing because it correlates with productivity and output. it could also be that you struggle to delegate because you don't trust others, or maybe you focus on your career or academics because you're scared to let yourself have a life outside of those things. You keep yourself preoccupied because you want to have that excuse to cancel plans and a pretty socially admirable excuse as well to not spend time with loved ones or to be by yourself for long periods of time. And academics and our careers, they're a really great excuse because it's very socially acceptable. But what it's concealing is that you're actually avoiding situations that require dependence or asking for help and letting people in.
Your performance and success works to further support the belief that your hyper-independence is a good thing because it correlates with productivity and output. it could also be that you struggle to delegate because you don't trust others, or maybe you focus on your career or academics because you're scared to let yourself have a life outside of those things. You keep yourself preoccupied because you want to have that excuse to cancel plans and a pretty socially admirable excuse as well to not spend time with loved ones or to be by yourself for long periods of time. And academics and our careers, they're a really great excuse because it's very socially acceptable. But what it's concealing is that you're actually avoiding situations that require dependence or asking for help and letting people in.|||你的表现和成功进一步支撑了这样一种信念：你的过度独立是一件好事，因为它与生产力和产出挂钩。这也可能是因为你不信任他人而难以将工作分派出去，或者你专注于事业或学业，是因为你害怕让自己在这些事情之外拥有生活。你让自己忙得不可开交，因为你想借此作为取消计划的借口，这也是一个在社会上相当令人钦佩的借口，可以不用花时间陪伴亲人，或者可以长时间独自呆着。学业和我们的职业生涯，它们真的是个极好的借口，因为它们在社会上非常被接受。但它所掩盖的是，你实际上是在逃避那些需要依赖、寻求帮助以及让别人进入你生活的处境。
And finally, if it's not already obvious, you prefer to do things alone and on your own schedule. And you find that other people slow you down. You don't want to wait for others. You're on the girl's trip. no one else wants to come with you to the museum or whatever. Not only does that not bother you, but you prefer it. It's like a sigh of relief. And I think sometimes this comes off as arrogance or even introversion, which it isn't.
And finally, if it's not already obvious, you prefer to do things alone and on your own schedule. And you find that other people slow you down. You don't want to wait for others. You're on the girl's trip. no one else wants to come with you to the museum or whatever. Not only does that not bother you, but you prefer it. It's like a sigh of relief. And I think sometimes this comes off as arrogance or even introversion, which it isn't.|||最后，如果这还不明显的话，你更喜欢独自一人、按照自己的时间表做事。你觉得别人会拖慢你的节奏。你不想等别人。你正在进行闺蜜之旅。别人不想跟你一起去博物馆或其他地方。这不仅不会困扰你，反而正是你所偏爱的。这就像是长舒了一口气。我认为有时这会表现为傲慢甚至内向，但其实并不是。
It's a trauma response to push others away and be self-contained because you have learnt that you can only rely on yourself and you don't want to be disappointed by those close to you. But when you isolate yourself, you're also repressing your emotions. and neglecting your needs. You may believe that your hyper independence is keeping you safe, but those close to you, those who care about you deeply, they want to be able to reach out. We understand that community is valuable,
It's a trauma response to push others away and be self-contained because you have learnt that you can only rely on yourself and you don't want to be disappointed by those close to you. But when you isolate yourself, you're also repressing your emotions. and neglecting your needs. You may believe that your hyper independence is keeping you safe, but those close to you, those who care about you deeply, they want to be able to reach out. We understand that community is valuable,|||把别人推开并保持自给自足是一种创伤反应，因为你已经学会了你只能依靠自己，你不想被身边的人失望。但当你孤立自己时，你也在压抑自己的情感，忽视自己的需求。你可能相信你的过度独立在保护你的安全，但是那些亲近你的人，那些深深关心你的人，他们希望能够向你伸出援手。我们明白社群是有价值的，
and when you create that distance, it really puts you in a place of solitude. We're going to discuss that in just a second, but if you relate to these signs, it may be indicative of hyperindependence. It's important to remember that it is a spectrum though. Independence is good. But when it comes at the expense of healthy, meaningful relationships, of trust, of asking for help,
and when you create that distance, it really puts you in a place of solitude. We're going to discuss that in just a second, but if you relate to these signs, it may be indicative of hyperindependence. It's important to remember that it is a spectrum though. Independence is good. But when it comes at the expense of healthy, meaningful relationships, of trust, of asking for help,|||而当你制造出那种距离时，它确实把你置于一个孤独的境地。我们马上就会讨论这一点，但如果你对这些迹象感同身受，这可能预示着过度独立。不过，重要的是要记住它是一个光谱。独立是好的。但当它是以牺牲健康、有意义的关系、信任以及寻求帮助为代价时，
that is when it's in the territory of hyperindependence or counter-dependency. This is in contrast to codependency, in which we see people have this unhealthy need for approval and love and comfort of someone else to feel secure. while someone who is hyper-independent focuses on securing their own needs, sometimes at their detriment, and becoming entirely self-sufficient, someone who is codependent will consistently place the needs of others above their own in order to satisfy that deep desire to be attached to another person. We did a whole episode on this, you know, this kind of dynamic a little while back. But interestingly, something I didn't mention is that the independent behavior of hyper-independent people
that is when it's in the territory of hyperindependence or counter-dependency. This is in contrast to codependency, in which we see people have this unhealthy need for approval and love and comfort of someone else to feel secure. while someone who is hyper-independent focuses on securing their own needs, sometimes at their detriment, and becoming entirely self-sufficient, someone who is codependent will consistently place the needs of others above their own in order to satisfy that deep desire to be attached to another person. We did a whole episode on this, you know, this kind of dynamic a little while back. But interestingly, something I mentioned is that the independent behavior of hyper-independent people|||这才是进入了过度独立或反依赖的领域。这与共生依赖（codependency）形成鲜明对比，在共生依赖中，我们看到人们有一种不健康的需要，即需要获得他人的认可、爱和安慰才能感到安全。而过度独立的人则专注于满足自己的需求（有时甚至是以损害自身利益为代价），并变得完全自给自足；相比之下，共生依赖的人会始终将他人的需求置于自己的需求之上，以满足与另一个人建立依恋的深切渴望。不久前，我们针对这种动态关系做了一整期节目。但有趣的是，我之前提到过的一点是，过度独立之人的独立行为
can actually be highly attractive to people who are codependent, because it provides a sense of security and structure and self-sufficiency that they lack and are therefore craving. However, once in a relationship, if one was to form between a hyper-independent person and a codependent person, sometimes we see this actual, this role reversal. No one quite knows why. There are a couple of theories out there that what these people are really looking for is the comfort of an opposite. Someone who can allow them to relinquish the control that either their codependence or hyperindependence has given them. The partner offers everything they cannot offer themselves, represents what they cannot offer themselves. And in order to kind of ignite a romance, they attempt to emulate that other person's behavior
can actually be highly attractive to people who are codependent, because it provides a sense of security and structure and self-sufficiency that they lack and are therefore craving. However, once in a relationship, if one was to form between a hyper-independent person and a codependent person, sometimes we see this actual, this role reversal. No one quite knows why. There are a couple of theories out there that what these people are really looking for is the comfort of an opposite. Someone who can allow them to relinquish the control that either their codependence or hyperindependence has given them. The partner offers everything they cannot offer themselves, represents what they cannot offer themselves. And in order to kind of ignite a romance, they attempt to emulate that other person's behavior|||实际上对共生依赖者具有极大的吸引力，因为它提供了一种他们所缺乏并因此而渴望的安全感、结构感和自给自足感。然而，一旦确立了恋爱关系（如果过度独立者与共生依赖者之间真的形成这种关系的话），有时我们会看到这种实际的角色互换。没有人确切知道为什么。外界有几种理论认为，这些人真正寻找的是对立面的慰藉。一个能让他们放弃由共生依赖或过度独立所赋予的控制权的人。伴侣提供了他们自己无法提供的一切，代表了他们自己无法提供的东西。为了点燃浪漫火花，他们试图去模仿另一个人的行为
leading to this kind of dynamic shift. Regardless, I think both hyperindependence and codependence are what we would call maladaptive. We're specifically focusing on hyper independence in this episode. And the reason psychologists and therapists see this behavioral pattern as particularly unhealthy is that we all still have some basic need for, for social connection and trust and vulnerability. That need does not disappear, regardless of how much we try and actively suppress this instinct. And so there's this element of our emotional and mental well-being
leading to this kind of dynamic shift. Regardless, I think both hyperindependence and codependence are what we would call maladaptive. We're specifically focusing on hyper independence in this episode. And the reason psychologists and therapists see this behavioral pattern as particularly unhealthy is that we all still have some basic need for, for social connection and trust and vulnerability. That need does not disappear, regardless of how much we try and actively suppress this instinct. And so there's this element of our emotional and mental well-being|||从而导致这种动态的转变。无论如何，我认为过度独立和共生依赖都是我们所谓的适应不良（maladaptive）。我们在本期节目中专门关注过度独立。心理学家和治疗师之所以认为这种行为模式特别不健康，是因为我们所有人内心深处仍然对社会联系、信任和脆弱感有着某种基本的需求。这种需求不会消失，无论我们如何试图积极压抑这种本能。因此，在我们情感和心理健康的构成中，有这样一个要素，
that is not fulfilled, a need that we're kind of subconsciously denying ourselves because we value independence and we value being able to detach from others and kind of borrow into our own thoughts and our own feelings. I think it's interesting because people who are hyper-independent are often very attached to this aspect of their identity. What's also true, though, is that these people still experience really profound loneliness. They experience poor self-esteem,
that is not fulfilled, a need that we're kind of subconsciously denying ourselves because we value independence and we value being able to detach from others and kind of burrow into our own thoughts and our own feelings. I think it's interesting because people who are hyper-independent are often very attached to this aspect of their identity. What's also true, though, is that these people still experience really profound loneliness. They experience poor self-esteem,|||它没有得到满足，这个需求我们在潜意识里一直在对自己进行否认，因为我们珍视独立，珍视能够摆脱他人并钻进自己的思想和情感中的能力。我觉得这很有趣，因为过度独立的人往往对他们身份认同的这一部分非常执着。不过同样真实的是，这些人仍然会经历极其深重的孤独感。他们的自尊心较差，
and their relationships often lack that emotional intimacy. I think hyper-independency really shares. a lot of commonalities with emotional unavailability in this way, but not because these individuals don't want to be close to others, but because they cannot give up that self-sufficiency. Studies have shown that this kind of behavior likely stems from a few core experiences, particularly childhood trauma that has taught us to trust ourselves and only ourselves to get through life. often that mistrust comes from a place of deep hurt that has taught us this fallacy that no one can be trusted
and their relationships often lack that emotional intimacy. I think hyper-independency really shares. a lot of commonalities with emotional unavailability in this way, but not because these individuals don't want to be close to others, but because they cannot give up that self-sufficiency. Studies have shown that this kind of behavior likely stems from a few core experiences, particularly childhood trauma that has taught us to trust ourselves and only ourselves to get through life. often that mistrust comes from a place of deep hurt that has taught us this fallacy that no one can be trusted|||他们的关系往往缺乏那种情感上的亲密感。我认为过度独立在这方面确实与情感冷漠（emotional unavailability）有很多共同点，但并不是因为这些个体不想与他人亲近，而是因为他们无法放弃那种自给自足。研究表明，这种行为可能源于一些核心经历，特别是童年创伤，它教会了我们去相信自己，并且只能相信自己来度过一生。这种不信任往往来自一处深重的伤痛，它教给我们一个谬论：没有人是值得信任的，
with our happiness or welfare. There are three distinct types of trauma that it may be in response to and that I want to focus on. The first is emotional neglect, parentification and abandonment. As children, we have a lot of emotional needs, physical needs, social needs, social needs, needs that need to be fulfilled in order for our brains to develop and our social skills as well. When our caregivers, normally our parents, don't sufficiently respond to those needs by shutting down our emotions, by a failure to provide encouragement or emotional unavailability, being totally absent, being overly busy, or just not showing up for us when they said that they would, children learn that people are unreliable. Studies have shown that when we experience this
with our happiness or welfare. There are three distinct types of trauma that it may be in response to and that I want to focus on. The first is emotional neglect, parentification and abandonment. As children, we have a lot of emotional needs, physical needs, social needs, social needs, needs that need to be fulfilled in order for our brains to develop and our social skills as well. When our caregivers, normally our parents, don't sufficiently respond to those needs by shutting down our emotions, by a failure to provide encouragement or emotional unavailability, being totally absent, being overly busy, or just not showing up for us when they said that they would, children learn that people are unreliable. Studies have shown that when we experience this|||我们的幸福或福祉托付给他人。它可能是对三种不同类型的创伤的反应，这也是我想要重点关注的。第一种是情感忽视、亲职化和遗弃。作为孩子，我们有很多情感需求、身体需求、社交需求，这些需求需要得到满足，以便我们的大脑能够发育，我们的社交技能也能随之发展。当我们的照顾者（通常是我们的父母）没有充分回应这些需求时，他们通过关闭我们的情绪、未能提供鼓励、情感冷漠、完全缺席、过度忙碌，或者只是在承诺会出现时却没有出现，孩子们便会了解到人是不可靠的。研究表明，当我们经历这种
kind of neglect, there are reduced levels of oxytocin in the brain. This is incredibly valuable for organising our neural circuits, especially in response to recognizing and being able to respond to emotions and social bonding. So as a result, children who are raised in an environment where their caregivers do not provide them with the right amount of emotional stimulation for oxytocin release, they are more at risk of emotional detachment and emotional impairment, perhaps contributing to this hyper-independency. From a social learning perspective, this child also learns that their emotional needs will not be met unless they meet them themselves, and that others will inherently disappoint them, leading once again to hyperindependence.
kind of neglect, there are reduced levels of oxytocin in the brain. This is incredibly valuable for organising our neural circuits, especially in response to recognizing and being able to respond to emotions and social bonding. So as a result, children who are raised in an environment where their caregivers do not provide them with the right amount of emotional stimulation for oxytocin release, they are more at risk of emotional detachment and emotional impairment, perhaps contributing to this hyper-independency. From a social learning perspective, this child also learns that their emotional needs will not be met unless they meet them themselves, and that others will inherently disappoint them, leading once again to hyperindependence.|||类的忽视时，大脑中的催产素水平会降低。这对于组织我们的神经回路具有难以置信的价值，尤其是在识别并能够对情绪和社交纽带作出反应方面。因此，在照顾者没有为他们提供适量的情感刺激以释放催产素的环境中长大的儿童，他们面临情感冷漠和情感损伤的风险更高，这或许也促成了这种过度独立。从社会学习的角度来看，这样的孩子也懂得了：除非自己满足自己的情感需求，否则他们的需求将永远无法得到满足，并且别人本质上都会让他们失望，从而再次导致了过度独立。
Similar to this is what we call parentification. So this occurs when the role of the parent and the child is almost reversed such that a child takes on the role of parent. They provide their parents with an unnatural level of emotional support. Maybe they have to worry about money. They're responsible for taking care of their siblings, keeping the house clean, worrying how they'll get to school, or the child is forced to take on this role of mediator or a confidant for a parent. This is most often seen with the firstborn and in certain cultures, normally the firstborn daughter because they are the ones who are more conditioned to be the emotional anchor for the family. sometimes parents don't realize that they have made their child their parent and they're not realizing
Similar to this is what we call parentification. So this occurs when the role of the parent and the child is almost reversed such that a child takes on the role of parent. They provide their parents with an unnatural level of emotional support. Maybe they have to worry about money. They're responsible for taking care of their siblings, keeping the house clean, worrying how they'll get to school, or the child is forced to take on this role of mediator or a confidant for a parent. This is most often seen with the firstborn and in certain cultures, normally the firstborn daughter because they are the ones who are more conditioned to be the emotional anchor for the family. sometimes parents don't realize that they have made their child their parent and they're not realizing|||与此相似的是我们所说的“亲职化”（parentification）。这种情况发生在父母和孩子的角色几乎发生逆转时，以至于孩子承担起了父母的角色。他们向父母提供超乎常理的情感支持。也许他们必须为钱操心。他们负责照顾兄弟姐妹、保持家里清洁、担心如何去学校，或者孩子被迫扮演父母的调解员或知己的角色。这种情况在长子长女身上以及在某些文化中最常见，通常是长女，因为她们更有条件成为家庭的情感支柱。有时父母没有意识到他们把自己的孩子当成了父母，也没有意识到
the burden that this places on their children more often than not it's generational and actually we see this a lot with people whose parents have gone through a divorce especially if the divorce was hostile the children end up becoming the messengers for either party and they're kind of exposed to a developmentally inappropriate level of emotional responsibility and they feel like they have to give up their needs, particularly their need for emotional security and stability for the sake of their parents' well-being. That is so hard on our young brains and we unconsciously adopt this parental level of responsibility. We grow up way too quickly and as a response to that, in response to that environment, we become hyper-independent as a coping mechanism, as a trauma response to our
the burden that this places on their children more often than not it's generational and actually we see this a lot with people whose parents have gone through a divorce especially if the divorce was hostile the children end up becoming the messengers for either party and they're kind of exposed to a developmentally inappropriate level of emotional responsibility and they feel like they have to give up their needs, particularly their need for emotional security and stability for the sake of their parents' well-being. That is so hard on our young brains and we unconsciously adopt this parental level of responsibility. We grow up way too quickly and as a response to that, in response to that environment, we become hyper-independent as a coping mechanism, as a trauma response to our|||这给他们的孩子带来了多么沉重的负担。通常情况下，这是代际相传的。事实上，我们在那些父母经历过离婚的人身上经常看到这一点，尤其是如果离婚过程充满敌意的话，孩子们最终会成为双方的传话筒，他们被迫承受了与其发育阶段不相称的情感责任水平，并且他们觉得为了父母的福祉，他们必须放弃自己的需求，尤其是对情感安全和稳定性的需求。这对我们年幼的大脑来说太难了，我们在不知不觉中承担了这种父母级别的责任。我们成长得太快了，为了应对这种情况，为了应对那种环境，我们把过度独立当作一种应对机制，作为我们对
circumstances, to protect our young brains, to respond to our environment appropriately, to kind of keep the peace. You become the parent, you become the adult way too young. Finally, we have abandonment. When we are let down by the people who are meant to care for us, we learn to become self-sufficient in order to A, survive, but B, to not be disappointed. That's where this idea of hyper-independence as a trauma response really comes from. A trauma response in psychology, it's an emotional response to an event or a series of events that injure our sense of security. I think there's this misconception that these have to be incredibly intense and catastrophic, like a war or serious death or injury.
circumstances, to protect our young brains, to respond to our environment appropriately, to kind of keep the peace. You become the parent, you become the adult way too young. Finally, we have abandonment. When we are let down by the people who are meant to care for us, we learn to become self-sufficient in order to A, survive, but B, to not be disappointed. That's where this idea of hyper-independence as a trauma response really comes from. A trauma response in psychology, it's an emotional response to an event or a series of events that injure our sense of security. I think there's this misconception that these have to be incredibly intense and catastrophic, like a war or serious death or injury.|||环境的创伤反应，来保护我们年轻的大脑，以适当地对环境作出反应，从而维持某种程度的和平。你成了父母，你太年轻就成了成年人。最后，我们来谈谈遗弃。当我们被本该照顾我们的人辜负时，我们学会了自给自足，以便A，能够生存，但B，不再感到失望。这就是过度独立作为一种创伤反应的真正来源。在心理学中，创伤反应是对损害我们安全感的某一事件或一系列事件的情感反应。我认为存在这样一种误解，即这些事件必须极其剧烈且具有灾难性，比如战争或严重的死亡或受伤。
that's not true. Things like emotional abuse, neglect, they leave just as permanent psychological scars. Also, our brains are all incredibly unique. I always say this, but it's worth a reminder, trauma is subjective. And when we experience a traumatic event that is particularly triggering or damaging for us, our body and our mind responds by entering survival mode. This is also called our fight, flight or freeze response. The mind is going to wait till after the danger has passed to try and find a way to explain that event and neatly tie it all together or consolidate what you've experienced. When it cannot do that, when it cannot find an explanation or a place for that memory to be put in our brains, we experience those lingering impacts and a sense of distress or
that's not true. Things like emotional abuse, neglect, they leave just as permanent psychological scars. Also, our brains are all incredibly unique. I always say this, but it's worth a reminder, trauma is subjective. And when we experience a traumatic event that is particularly triggering or damaging for us, our body and our mind responds by entering survival mode. This is also called our fight, flight or freeze response. The mind is going to wait till after the danger has passed to try and find a way to explain that event and neatly tie it all together or consolidate what you've experienced. When it cannot do that, when it cannot find an explanation or a place for that memory to be put in our brains, we experience those lingering impacts and a sense of distress or|||事实并非如此。像情感虐待、忽视这样的事情，同样会留下永久的心理伤痕。此外，我们的大脑都是无比独特的。我经常这么说，但这值得提醒的是，创伤是主观的。当我们经历了一场对我们而言特别容易触发或具有破坏性的创伤事件时，我们的身体和心灵会通过进入生存模式做出反应。这也称为我们的战斗、逃跑或僵住反应。大脑会一直等到危险过去之后，才试图寻找一种方法来解释该事件，并将其整齐地联系在一起，或者巩固你所经历的事情。当它无法做到这一点时，当它找不到解释或无法在我们的大脑中为该记忆安放位置时，我们就会经历挥之不去的负面影响以及痛苦感或
impaired behavioral patterns such as this self-sufficiency. It's also possible to have what we would call a delayed emotional response. Maybe in the years that have followed, perhaps your parents' divorce or the neglect, you didn't notice your hyperindependence. But then you enter into your first relationship or you start dating and begin to recognize some of those signs that we talked about before. This is, I think, especially the case if the relationship mimics the dynamic that you had with your parents. Perhaps this person never shows up for you. They're emotionally unavailable or they do something that breaks your trust. This just reinforces all of that childhood learning and it can result in delayed hyperindependency. The opposite's also true. Someone showers you and
impaired behavioral patterns such as this self-sufficiency. It's also possible to have what we would call a delayed emotional response. Maybe in the years that have followed, perhaps your parents' divorce or the neglect, you didn't notice your hyperindependence. But then you enter into your first relationship or you start dating and begin to recognize some of those signs that we talked about before. This is, I think, especially the case if the relationship mimics the dynamic that you had with your parents. Perhaps this person never shows up for you. They're emotionally unavailable or they do something that breaks your trust. This just reinforces all of that childhood learning and it can result in delayed hyperindependency. The opposite's also true. Someone showers you and|||受损的行为模式，例如这种过度独立。也有可能会产生我们所谓的延迟性情感反应。也许在随后的几年里，或许是你父母的离婚或那场忽视之后，你没有注意到自己的过度独立。但当你开始第一段恋爱或开始约会时，你开始认出我们之前谈到的一些迹象。我认为，如果这种恋爱关系模仿了你与父母之间的互动模式，尤其会是这样。也许这个人从未为你出现过。他们情感冷漠，或者他们做了打破你信任的事。这只会强化所有那些童年的学习经验，并可能导致延迟性的过度独立。反之亦然。有人对你倾注了
love and affection, they consistently show up in your life. They celebrate you. They provide security. That can be equally scary because you've learned to do things alone. You have adopted this mentality that you don't need anyone. So the love shown by this person causes you to really question everything. And it makes you scared because it's not the truth that you've accepted. It's not the reality that you know. I think it takes a lot from us to give up our hyper independence because for so long it has protected us, but what does that kind of come at the expense of? So I really want to discuss that next, specifically the long-term consequences of hyper-independence, as well as some of the maintaining factors, specifically around the role of culture and social psychology. So all of that and more in just a second.
love and affection, they consistently show up in your life. They celebrate you. They provide security. That can be equally scary because you've learned to do things alone. You have adopted this mentality that you don't need anyone. So the love shown by this person causes you to really question everything. And it makes you scared because it's not the truth that you've accepted. It's not the reality that you know. I think it takes a lot from us to give up our hyper independence because for so long it has protected us, but what does that kind of come at the expense of? So I really want to discuss that next, specifically the long-term consequences of hyper-independence, as well as some of the maintaining factors, specifically around the role of culture and social psychology. So all of that and more in just a second.|||爱与关怀，他们始终如一地出现在你的生活中。他们为你庆祝。他们提供安全感。这可能会同样令人恐慌，因为你已经习惯了独自做事。你已经养成了“不需要任何人”的心态。因此，这个人表现出的爱让你开始真正质疑一切。这让你感到害怕，因为它不是你所接受的真理。它不是你所熟知的现实。我认为放弃我们的过度独立需要我们付出很多，因为长久以来它一直在保护我们，但那种保护是以什么为代价的呢？所以我接下来非常想讨论这个问题，特别是过度长期的后果，以及一些维持这种状态的因素，特别是围绕文化和社会心理学的作用。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.|||2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾坚信种子油本身具有炎症性。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.|||让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字“TWO-Persent”，可在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（或：袭胸）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？你可以在《回看过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of... crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of... crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.|||我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当年发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为……快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二期讨论快克了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your|||所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》
podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase|||播客。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.|||以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要吗，还是说你成为一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app,
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app,|||绝对是。而且那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正成为一个好人。加入我和凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App，
Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
收听《用惨痛教训学习》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对某个人特别篡改了这个测试两次，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of... served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So far, we've explored what causes hyperindependence to emerge, especially as it relates to a trauma response.
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，美里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州正义得到声张之前，这一切都还没有结束...。在Iheart电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。到目前为止，我们已经探讨了导致过度独立出现的原因，特别是当它与创伤反应有关时。
But I also want to look at some of the maintaining factors, as well as the psychology behind, I guess, the healing work and the way that we can move forward. One of the biggest factors that exacerbates hyperindependency is culture and societal context. In psychology, we have this distinction between individualistic and collectivist cultures. In a collectivist society, the needs of the group are more important and people, I guess, are often asked to sacrifice individual benefits for the collective good. their identity and the group identity are equally valuable. However, in individualistic societies, what matters most is individual success, is freedom and independence.
但我也想看看一些维持因素，以及治愈工作背后的心理学以及我们可以前进的方式。加剧过度独立的最主要因素之一是文化和社会的背景。在心理学中，我们将个人主义文化和集体主义文化区分开来。在集体主义社会中，群体的需求更为重要，人们，我想，经常被要求为了集体利益而牺牲个人的利益。他们的身份和群体的身份具有同等价值。然而，在个人主义社会中，最重要的是个人的成功、自由和独立。
Societies with this kind of individualistic culture, we kind of, we treat people as autonomous and we prioritize personal gain and uniqueness. And in these types of societies such as the U.S., the UK, Australia, many Western, Western societies, hyper-independence is often overlooked and rarely challenged because people are allowed to exist as unique, self-reliant humans without challenging kind of the group dynamic and the general good. We see this a lot, especially with the Western idea of exceptionalism in which devoting every hour of our life to our career, neglecting personal relationships, not asking for help,
具有这种个人主义文化的社会，我们某种程度上将人们视为自主的，我们优先考虑个人的利益和独特性。而在这些类型的社会中，例如美国、英国、澳大利亚、许多西方社会，过度独立往往被忽视，很少受到挑战，因为人们被允许作为独特的、自力更生的个体存在，而无需挑战群体动态和总体利益。我们经常看到这一点，特别是西方的精英主义思想，即把我们生命中的每一个小时都奉献给事业，忽视个人关系，不寻求帮助，
that is seen as admirable. But we also know that that is very much maladaptive. Whilst this response or behavioral pattern may leave you feeling safe and secure because you're not challenged by vulnerability or close relationships, what drives this hyperindependency is an avoidance mindset. avoiding intimacy, avoiding trust, avoiding vulnerability, avoiding help, avoiding company.
这被认为是令人钦佩的。但我们也知道这是非常适应不良的。虽然这种反应或行为模式可能会让你感到安全和放心，因为你没有受到脆弱性或亲密关系的挑战，但驱动这种过度独立的动机是一种逃避型的心态。逃避亲密感，逃避信任，逃避脆弱，逃避帮助，逃避陪伴。
And whilst we may have kind of superficially positive relationships, because we fundamentally do not trust others, that we are unable to form those long-term, meaningful partnerships. Even in marriages, I saw this really interesting fact. Someone who is counterdependent or hyper-independent, they'll continue to, to hide core aspects of their emotions. They will resist asking for assistance and will be reluctant to open up even from someone that they've married. They're going to avoid situations requiring deep emotional connection because that requires the possibility of being hurt. That requires the possibility of challenging this belief that maybe they are not self-sufficient, that maybe they can't do everything
虽然我们可能有表面上积极的关系，但因为我们从根本上不信任他人，我们无法形成那些长期的、有意义的伙伴关系。即使在婚姻中，我也看到了一个非常有趣的事实。一个反依赖或过度独立的人，他们会继续隐藏其情绪的核心方面。他们会抗拒寻求帮助，即使对他们已经结婚的人也勉于敞开心扉。他们会避开需要深度情感连接的情况，因为那需要承担受伤的可能性。那需要打破这种信念的可能性，即也许他们并不是自给自足的，也许他们无法做所有事情
on their own. I think we can all see how this can create a pretty unfulfilling life, especially since we are social beings. We have evolved around this idea of community, around this idea of a social structure that helps others. You know, relationships by nature are also interdependent. So to have successful long-term relationships, some aspect of our hyper-independence is going to have to be relinquished. So let's discuss some of the ways that psychology and therapy might help us heal this tendency and restore a healthy level of independence or a healthy level of dependence on others. We're going to discuss three tips. Firstly, addressing trust issues and attachment style, the value of inner child healing and recognizing what triggers you and when you need help.
靠他们自己。我想我们都能看到这如何能创造一个相当没有成就感的生活，尤其是因为我们是社会性动物。我们围绕着社区的这个概念进化，围绕着一个帮助他人的社会结构的概念。你知道，关系本质上也是相互依存的。因此，要拥有成功的长期关系，我们过度独立的某些方面将不得不被放弃。因此，让我们讨论一些心理学和治疗可能帮助我们治愈这种倾向并恢复健康的独立水平或对他人健康的依赖水平的方法。我们将讨论三个建议。首先，解决信任问题和依恋风格，内在小孩疗愈的价值以及识别你的触发点以及你何时需要帮助。
addressing trust issues and attachment style, it involves understanding that interplay between our past experiences and our current emotional patterns. Trust issues simply put are this persistent lack of confidence and faith in others. They are a fear response and they can't be challenged overnight, sadly, but they can be through a gradual process of exposure to situations that may trigger your hyper-independency, specifically emotionally vulnerable situations, times when you need to ask for help, combined with positive reward and calming techniques. This intervention is actually mainly used in treating phobias. It's called exposure therapy, and it involves a gradual exposure to an event that creates anxiety at small levels and we increase the anxiety it creates
解决信任问题和依恋风格，它涉及理解我们过去经验与当前情感模式之间的相互作用。简而言之，信任问题是对他人持续缺乏信心和信念。它们是一种恐惧反应，可悲的是，它们无法在一夜之间被挑战，但可以通过逐渐暴露于可能触发你过度独立的情境的过程来解决，特别是情感脆弱的情境，需要寻求帮助的时刻，结合积极的奖励和镇静技巧。这种干预实际上主要用于治疗恐惧症。它被称为暴露疗法，它涉及逐渐暴露于以微小水平产生焦虑的事件中，并且我们增加它产生的焦虑
over time whilst combining it with something positive, whilst combining it with calming exercises so that that stress response so that that hyper-independency is not triggered. So this could involve slowly sharing personal experiences, delegating responsibility, or relying on someone for support. Every time these experiences go well, every time you learn that you can trust those around you, that they will show up, that life is maybe easier if you let people in,
随着时间的推移，同时将其与积极的事情结合起来，同时将其与镇静练习结合起来，以便不触发压力反应，不触发过度独立。因此，这可能涉及慢慢分享个人经验，委派责任，或依靠某人寻求支持。每当这些经历进展顺利时，每当你了解到你可以信任周围的人，他们会出现，如果你让人们进来，生活可能会更轻松，
you unlearn those lessons and that trauma that has convinced you that self-sufficiency is the only way to get through life. However, it's also important that we don't go too far, like we spoke of before, hyper-independent people are often more attracted to people who are codependent because they like the responsibility of managing the relationship and feeling like they can be autonomous because the other person won't question them. That codependent person just wants to make you happy. We're working towards interdependence here, not codependence.
你就会消除那些说服你自给自足是度过一生的唯一途径的教训和创伤。然而，同样重要的是，我们不要走得太远，正如我们之前所说，过度独立的人往往更容易被那些相互依赖的人吸引，因为他们喜欢管理关系的责任，并觉得他们可以自主，因为另一个人不会质疑他们。那个相互依存的人只是想让你快乐。我们在这里努力实现相互依存，而不是相互依赖过度（共依存）。
So it's important to make sure that you recognize what your kind of boundaries are, that you can still say no so that you don't swing in the opposite direction. I think emotional extremes are also a massive indicator of a trauma response or of hyper-independency. So making sure that you're like, okay, this relationship, I might be going a little bit too far. Maybe I'm just decided to attach myself to one person because I can trust them. That's like hyper-independency, like spicy hyper-independency almost. like you're still hyper-independent plus one, plus this one additional person. We also know that one of the root causes of hyper-independency is having to grow up too quickly.
因此，确保你认识到你的界限是什么，你仍然可以说“不”，这样你就不会向相反的方向摇摆，这一点很重要。我认为情绪极端也是创伤反应或过度独立的巨大指标。所以确保你认为，好吧，这段关系，我可能走得有点远。也许我只是决定依附于一个人，因为我可以信任他们。这就像过度独立，就像辛辣的过度独立。就像你仍然是过度独立加一，加上这另外一个人。我们也知道，过度独立的一个根本原因是不得不成长得太快。
You've become an adult way before your time. So to heal the current version of ourselves, the hyper-independent version of ourselves, we also need to heal those previous versions. That includes our younger childhood selves. This is where inner child healing becomes really useful. The essential premise is that we have all experienced hurt in some way. And in order to heal our adult emotional scars and beliefs, we need to get back to those foundational experiences that we had as children.
你在远早于你应有的时间成为了一个成年人。因此，为了治愈我们当前的自己，我们过度独立的版本，我们还需要治愈那些之前的版本。这包括我们更年轻的童年自己。这就是内在小孩治愈变得非常有用的时候。基本的前提是我们在某种程度上都经历过伤害。为了治愈我们成年人的情感伤疤和信念，我们需要回到我们在童年时期拥有的那些基础经历。
And we need to begin treating ourselves as if we are the parent, as if we are caring for that childhood version of us. It goes by another name and that's called re-parenting. And I think that's the crucial idea here. We have to be the parent that we always deserved, whether you had a healthy example of what that should look like or not. And by loving this version of us unconditionally, by deliberately and consciously healing them, giving them, perhaps what we did not have as children, we address the things that we most want to change about our adult cells. There are a few ways that we can do this that are specific to the emotional wounds most attached to hyper-independency. So emotional
我们需要开始像父母那样对待自己，就像我们在照顾我们童年的那个版本一样。它还有一个名字，叫做重新养育。我认为这是这里至关重要的想法。我们必须成为我们一直应得的父母，无论你是否有过这应该是什么样子的健康榜样。通过无条件地爱我们这个版本，通过刻意和有意识地治愈他们，给予他们，也许是我们小时候没有的东西，我们解决了我们最想改变的关于成年自己的事情。我们可以通过几种特定于与过度独立最相关的情感创伤的方法来做到这一点。所以情感
neglect and parentification, also abandonment. Firstly, engage in play. Give yourself the opportunity to be childlike, especially if that ability and that opportunity was taken away from you when you were younger. Watch movies from your childhood. Go on the swings. Make fairy bread. Pull out, you know, a board game, some uno cards, buy yourself something ridiculous and fluffy, a toy, a chocolate Sunday, just because you want to. Let yourself have those innocent childhood experiences that maybe you were not allowed to have when you were younger. Secondly, is to be messy and to be vulnerable. Allow yourself to cry openly,
忽视和家长化，还有遗弃。首先，参与游戏。给自己一个像孩子一样的机会，特别是如果这种能力和机会在你年轻时被剥夺了。观看你童年的电影。去玩秋千。做仙女面包。拿出一副棋盘游戏，一些UNO牌，给自己买一些荒谬而毛茸茸的东西，一个玩具，一个巧克力圣代，只因为你想。让自己拥有那些无辜的童年经历，也许你在年轻时不被允许拥有。其次，是变得凌乱和脆弱。允许自己公开哭泣，
to not always check everything off your to-do list, make space for the mistakes that you weren't allowed to make in childhood. That is essentially saying, I did not get the opportunity perhaps to make mistakes. I had to be on guard. I had to be self-reliant. I had to look after others. And so all of that innocence, all of that freedom, all of that room to be messy and vulnerable, those were experiences that perhaps I didn't have when I was younger, that I'm going to recreate and give myself as an adult. I think also when you
不总是把待办事项清单上的每件事都勾掉，为你在童年时不被允许犯的错误腾出空间。这本质上是在说，我可能没有机会犯错。我必须保持警惕。我必须自力更生。我必须照顾别人。所以所有这些天真，所有这些自由，所有这些变得凌乱和脆弱的空间，这些可能是我年轻时不曾有过的经历，我将在成年后重新创造并给自己。我也认为当你
feel your inner child seeking out love, especially when you feel loneliness or longing, give them what they crave, not for your current self, not for that version of yourself that might be really scared, but for that inner child who needs you to have their best interests at heart, reach out to a friend, even if it's difficult. Ask for help because that's what your inner child needs. It might not be what you think you need, but you're not the focus here. It's about what that inner version, that childhood version of yourself needs. And practice radical self-competitive. And practice radical self-competent. passion. We talk about this quite a bit on the show because it is so powerful. When you find that you've failed, when you've been rejected, when you feel unhappy with yourself, take note of your
感到你的内在小孩在寻找爱时，特别是当你感到孤独或渴望时，给他们他们渴望的东西，不是为了你现在的自己，不是为了那个可能真的很害怕的自己，而是为了那个需要你把他们的最大利益放在心上的内在小孩，向朋友伸出援手，即使这很困难。寻求帮助，因为那是你的内在小孩需要的。这可能不是你认为自己需要的，但你不是这里的焦点。这是关于内在版本、童年版本的自己所需要的东西。并练习激进的自我同情。并练习激进的自我同情。我们在节目中经常讨论这一点，因为它是如此强大。当你发现自己失败了，当你被拒绝时，当你对自己的现状感到不满意时，记下你的
inner dialogue and self-talk. And imagine that your five-year-old self is sitting in front of you right now. And you're saying those things to them. You would not yell at this five-year-old version of you. You wouldn't tell them that they're useless, that they're worthless. that they're stupid. So why would you say these things to yourself now? I think that when we become conscious of the fact that this version of us still exists, needs to be reparented, needs to be protected, our approach to our current versions of ourselves become a lot more fulfilling and a lot more peaceful and gentle. Finally, I would say recognize what triggers your hyper-independent. And I think in those moments, those are the times you most need to ask for help. We have to remember,
内心对话和自我对话。想象一下，你五岁时的自己现在正坐在你面前。你正在对他们说那些话。你不会对你五岁时的这个版本大喊大叫。你不会告诉他们他们一无是处，他们毫无价值。他们很愚蠢。那么你为什么现在要对自己说这些话呢？我认为，当我们意识到我们这个版本依然存在，需要被重新养育，需要被保护这一事实时，我们对待当前自己的方法就会变得更加充实、和平和温柔。最后，我想说要认识是什么触发了你的过度独立。我认为在那些时刻，正是你最需要寻求帮助的时候。我们必须记住，
hyper independence is a trauma response. So it's often going to be activated during times of excessive stress or emotional intensity when our mind resorts to that deeply ingrained coping mechanism because in the past, it's proved that it worked, even if it's at the expense of your long-term well-being. But it's your job to replace this behavior with a more positive one and recognize what kind of situations are catalysts for you shunning assistance, for you isolating yourself. Maybe that's an argument with a partner or a friend. Maybe it's when someone says they're really busy. Maybe it's when someone doesn't show up for you. When you know that you're going to isolate, go out instead. or ask others to join you whilst you're studying or you're busy at work.
过度独立是一种创伤反应。因此，它通常会在过度压力或情感强烈的时候被激活，此时我们的心灵求助于那个根深蒂固的应对机制，因为在过去，事实证明它是有效的，即使这是以牺牲你的长期健康为代价的。但你的工作是用更积极的行为取代这种行为，并认识到什么样的情境是你抛弃援助、孤立自己的催化剂。也许那是与伴侣或朋友的争吵。也许是当某人说他们真的很忙时。也许是当某人没有为你出现时。当你明知自己要孤立时，反而要走出去。或者请别人在你学习或忙于工作时加入你。
When you know you're going to be maybe hostile towards others and you feel this urge to push them away, let them in, let them know what you're going through. When you need help, ask for it. Even if it's not from someone in your life, maybe it's from a neighbour or even someone online, it's all about those small steps. As we always say, you've got to feel the fear and do it anyway, your future self. is going to thank you for breaking out of this pattern. I guess the final reminder for the day is that hyper-independence is going to convince you
当你明知自己可能会对他人怀有敌意，并且感到一种把他们推开的冲动时，让他们进来，让他们知道你正在经历什么。当你需要帮助时，说出来。即使它不是来自你生活中的某个人，也许是来自邻居甚至网上的某个人，这一切都关乎那些小小的步骤。正如我们常说的那样，你必须感受到恐惧并依然去做，你未来的自己会感谢你打破了这种模式。我想今天的最后一个提醒是，过度独立会说服你
that being alone, doing things alone, is better, is safe, is secure. But that is not always the case. And like I said, we evolved around this idea of interdependency and community. It's important to know that it's not your fault, I guess. Like this comes from traumatic experiences. It comes from emotional neglect or events that caused you to grow up way too quickly and learn that you could not trust others. But as we get older, it's also important to revisit some of those childhood or early patterns of behavior that have continued with us into adulthood and check in with ourselves to see if
独自一人，独自做事情，是更好的，是安全的，是有保障的。但事实并非总是如此。正如我所说，我们围绕着相互依存和社区的概念进化。重要的是要知道这并非你的错，我想。这来自于创伤经历。它来自于情感忽视或导致你成长得太快并了解到你无法信任他人的事件。但随着我们年龄的增长，同样重要的是重新审视一些伴随我们进入成年期的童年或早期行为模式，并审视我们自己，看看
they're still doing what we need them to do, if they are still what is best for us in this current state of life. So I think that that is all we have time for today. I really hope that this episode kind of provide you with a better understanding of this. I love seeing TikToks and Instagram videos and whatnot around psychological concepts, but I do often think that it ignores some of the deeper understanding that we need. So hopefully this provided you a little bit of that. And if you are someone who is listening to this being like, damn, this really called me out. I think that I am hyper-independent. Well, now you have some steps. Now you have some ideas of where to go from here. Definitely left me a bit shook when I read some of the research,
它们是否仍然在做我们需要它们做的事，它们是否仍然是我们在这个当前的生活状态下最好的选择。所以我想这就是我们今天所有的时间。我真的希望这集能为你提供对这一点的更好理解。我喜欢看关于心理学概念的TikTok和Instagram视频以及诸如此类的东西，但我确实经常认为它忽略了我们需要的一些更深入的理解。所以希望这为你提供了一点那样的理解。如果你是一个听了这个节目然后觉得，天哪，这真的说中了我的痛点的人。我想我是过度独立的。好吧，现在你有一些步骤了。现在你有一些关于从这里去哪里的想法了。当我阅读一些研究时，它确实让我感到有些震撼，
specifically around the attraction to codependent people. I was like, wow, that describes every relationship I've ever had. So you are not in this boat alone. But I do really hope that you enjoyed this episode. If you did, please feel free to share it with a friend, share it forward with someone who you think might need to hear this, who you think might enjoy it. As always, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I read every single review. And I just love seeing the community grow and seeing there are new people find.
特别是关于对相互依赖的人的吸引力。我想，哇，这描述了我经历过的每一段关系。所以你并不是孤单一人。但我真的希望你喜欢这一集。如果你喜欢，请随意与朋友分享，将其转发给你认为可能需要听到这个、可能喜欢它的人。一如既往，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的任何地方留下五星级评价。我阅读每一条评价。我只是喜欢看到社区的成长，看到每天都有新的人发现。
this show every single day. So if that's you, welcome, welcome if this is your first episode. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to see when things are coming out, please follow me at that psychology podcast. And I also have a Patreon, the psychology of your 20s. If you want to support this show a little bit more and support the kind of content that I'm putting out, we will be back next week with another episode. See you then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway. with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
这个节目。所以如果那是你，欢迎，如果这是你的第一集，欢迎。如果你有节目建议，如果你只是想看看事情什么时候出来，请在那个心理学播客关注我。我还有一个Patreon，你的二十岁心理学。如果你想对这个节目提供更多支持并支持我正在推出的内容，我们将在下周带着另一集回归。到时候见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听《用惨痛教训学习》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%.
进行坦诚的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话真的都不安全，但你正在与一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用惨痛教训学习》。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个陌生的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWO.%。
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们自己采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。听女朋友的话。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart电台应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。
On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回看》播客中。对1979年来说，对我来说这是一个大时刻。84对我来说很大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过它的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
84年是疯狂的一年。这是一个疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证有人性。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。